[woman speaking Ukrainian]
Her teacher called me to come to school.
She said my daughter was crying,
saying she'd be sent back and killed.
All the kids in the class were crying.
The teacher didn't know what was going on.
[man speaking Ukrainian]
Soon she was rejecting food,
and then she stopped responding
in general.
We don't know how this happened.
She was an athlete, went running,
was active at school.
[man speaking English] The immigrants
that developed the condition
seem to come
from certain parts of the world.
These children and their families
have almost exclusively
been subject to trauma.
[man speaking Ukrainian]
By the time we got to Sweden,
my son was under
a tremendous amount of stress.
[woman speaking English]
The children have seen a lot.
[man speaking English]
We're talking about children
who are really sick in a serious way.
[woman speaking English]
When I do the examination,
I tell the parents that,
"You are the ones
who are suffering
because of her condition.
This is a way of protection.
She is just waiting
for the situation to be better."